the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so in the midst of sort of
general concerns that the Trump team is
completely unprepared to be taking
control of the United States listen to
the list of problems that we now know
the Trump transition team is having
number one it is total and utter chaos
within the Trump and transition team
after the removal of chris christie and
the replacement of chris christie with
mike pens to actually run the transition
team itself and you might hope well that
decision was probably made for some
reason that would make the transition
team run more effectively but lo and
behold no the Obama administration
notified the press that they had not yet
received a memo from Mike Pence which
allows the Obama administration and the
incoming a president elect Trump
administration's to start formally
discussing how to hand off the
government that sort of a big deal you
sort of need to figure that out and have
limited time to do it this signed paper
did eventually show up hours late and
the weird thing is it was the same
document that Chris Christie had
previously signed when he was heading up
the transition team so it raises the
question of if the document wasn't
changed why couldn't the Trump team just
get Mike Pence to sign this piece of
paper and get it over to the Obama
administration Trump transition team
officials just didn't show up at the
Pentagon for discussions about that
transition Trump officials just didn't
show up at the Department of Energy
which by the way is responsible for
keeping those nuclear codes that we are
all really really scared about Trump
having anything to do with and no
business having anything to do with
those Trump's team officials just didn't
show up when the Department of Energy
was expecting them on Monday no one at
the Justice Department has heard from
the Trump team and the question is what
is causing all of this lack of
organization is part of it but
their element of the root cause is that
the Trump transition team and this is
insane who wouldn't want to be a part of
a presidential administration the Trump
team is having a difficult time finding
able-minded Republicans that are even
willing to work with them and Red Alert
a democratic source who like others
would only discuss what's going on on
the condition of anonymity said that
transition officials have been
informally asking Obama appointees to
recommend Republicans to take over their
jobs this is so pathetic guys they no
call no show and then they don't know
who to hire hey Obama administration
could you recommend some Republicans to
us so that we can maybe get this thing
moving what's pretty funny how chris
Christie was in charge of the transition
team when the prospect of a Donald Trump
presidency was just wishful thinking
yeah and now that it's become a reality
Mike Pence is in charge and Rachel I
mean when we think about this you've got
all of these Republicans everywhere who
seem desperate to have positions of
power all of a sudden now none of them
are jumping at the opportunity to work
in the Trump administration but I also
feel like because Trump doesn't have a
lot of experience he doesn't have this
long list of officials from the bush-era
to tap from so where is he looking to
yet well he was going to put the best
people around him and apparently he
can't even put people around him who can
then find people to put around him and
we're getting there several levels
removed here from Trump being the really
great manager that he says he's going to
be and very telling is that Elliot Cohen
who was a long time neo conservative
voice he tweeted about the total chaos
and disorder that's going on within the
Trump transition team we're gonna put
that tweet up for you saying after
exchange with Trump transition team
changed my recommendation stay away
they're angry arrogant screaming you
lost will be ugly and then in the midst
of this you have rinse Priebus according
to sources who is going to be the White
House chief of staff leaving his role as
RNC chair he is now very concerned about
the possibility of Corey Lewandowski
former Trump campaign manager and and
CNN contributor
corey lewandowski may be named RNC chair
and rinse Priebus is very concerned
about that the Republicans are scared of
what the Republicans under Trump are
going to do I understand that but kind
of going back to the unraveling I'm
wondering if the catalyst for this was
giving so much power to jared kushner
and saying oh he can make decisions kind
of based on emotions and saying I'm
going to dismiss Rodgers because uh when
Chris Christie was an a federal
prosecutor he put my father in jail or
saying uh that Rogers agreed with Obama
and saying that he had a he didn't
mislead the public in terms of Benghazi
and that's starkly contrast with Trump's
narrative about Benghazi so let's just
dismiss him yeah well jared kushner of
course Trump son-in-law who by all
indications has a very very uh has very
significant influence pad over Donald
Trump and it's unclear exactly what his
role is going to be in the
administration we haven't really heard
much about it I warned you Trump is not
qualified to run the country we've been
saying it for a while he likes the hunt
of it he likes the competition he wants
the power he sees associated with it but
now that he's won it's abundantly clear
he's not interested in governing and we
really don't know which sectors of the
Republican Party is going to be in
charge because there's the alt right
group like Steven Steven Bannon yeah and
then there's the more establishment
types like rhymes previous we don't know
who's gonna go and we're hearing about
Jionni a newt gingrich and some well
yeah but Giuliani says it's all fine
because this happened with Reagan and
Clinton so if this is normal yeah I
trust me Giuliani inherently especially
after he told us the FBI was leaking him
information or at least implied it I've
been talking about the Trump what I call
in stuff lips or backtracking with
regard to his campaign promises we
talked about that Mexico wall more than
likely it'll be some fencing on some
part of the southern border and of
course he'll claim that he did it in
made America great again by doing it
prosecuting Hillary Clinton which he
said he would do in in one of the
debates that seems like it is no longer
a priority anymore Obamacare which he
was just saying was a disaster during
the campaign he actually like some of
those provisions quote very much and one
of the trump major campaign promises
with tax cuts right huge tax cuts
Republicans will control the house
they'll control the Senate
control the White House if there is ever
an opportunity to do major major tax
cuts it's when Republicans will control
the House Senate and White House right
well it turns out that those tax cuts
probably are not going to be as large as
Donald Trump a bragged about and
promised during his campaign why well
actual people who know stuff are
insisting that they're just going to be
too expensive it would explode the
deficit like we've been saying for a
year costing somewhere between six and
seven trillion dollars this is called
the real world when Republicans are
concerned your tax cuts might be too big
you've hit rock bottom and House
Republicans put together a slightly more
deficit friendly idea and it's just it's
stunning guys that the the House
Republicans have to talk sense on tax
cuts to the president-elect were in a
bizarro world of some kind I know this
is somewhat standard but how is this
kind of going to affect the constructive
receipt tax doctrine or pay me in 2017
type of issue it's going to be a
disaster and and when we look at the
specifics of what Trump actually wants
to do he's already revised the income
tax rates that he promised so initially
he was talking about three income tax
rates ten percent twenty percent and
twenty five percent now he has changed
those to match those rates proposed by
the house plan to twelve percent twenty
five percent and thirty-three percent
another element of the house planet is a
bigger standard deduction on of federal
taxes there's also likely to be some
negotiations over the tax rate for small
businesses and partnerships currently
the rate is at thirty-five percent Trump
wants to go to fifteen percent for
corporations thirty-nine percent and
rather to fifteen percent from nearly
forty percent for foot sole
proprietorships and partnerships but the
house plan would only cut that up to
twenty five percent which is ten points
higher than what Donald Trump wants
there are major differences Pat between
what Trump has been running on and wants
to do and what Trump is already saying
he will do nevermind what the house is
saying that he should do in the things
that he ran on were spending proposals
things like the wall in the immigration
task force yeah but he never seemed to
come up with a way a pain
for it because he also promised ass cut
tax cuts yeah of course that's gonna
raise the deficit and this is the huge
huge huge red alert here which is that
the lowest tax rate under Trump's new
plan twelve percent is higher than the
lowest tax rate that already exists
right now think about how regressive
this tax cut is as is usually the case
with these right-wing tax cuts if Trump
goes for the house plan there will be a
tax break for the top point two percent
through no estate tax which is a
horribly regressive tax the top tax rate
for the highest earners would go from
thirty nine point six percent the
thirty-three percent the middle tax rate
would basically stay similar at
twenty-five percent but that lowest rate
would go from ten percent to twelve
percent we're talking about a tax
increase for some of those in the lowest
tax bracket what happened to helping the
little guy Rachel which is what Trump
ran on making America great again for
the middle classes I'm not really sure
but besides for swapping interest
deduction with expensing has he named a
single tax preference that he wants to
eliminate uh well let's see he wants to
eliminate I mean he talks about
loopholes getting rid of loopholes or
something I don't know about in waist
broaden ways were going to get rid of no
I have I mean he wants to change make
some changes to the mortgage deduction
mortgage interest deduction that's a
change right I suppose I just haven't
read anything specific yeah well that's
the problem with the trauma proposals
that there is nothing specific and and
most of them like all of the others
we've been talking about fall apart very
quickly when it's time to actually
legislate you can't write this stuff
former presidential candidate
neurosurgeon and hypnotherapist ben
Carson is not accepting a role in the
Trump in uh administration because wait
for it he doesn't have the experience
necessary to do so I mentioned last week
but ben Carson was being considered for
Secretary of Health and Human Services
it was reported early yesterday that he
actually had been offered the position
that he has not acknowledged that it was
built directly offered to him but
according to his business manager
strong Williams ben Carson will would
not or will not be accepting such a
position I'm gonna put up the
explanation from Armstrong Williams as
to why listen to this dr. Carson was
never offered a specific position but
everything was open to him dr. Carson
feels he has no government experience
he's never run a federal agency the last
thing he would want to do was take a
position that could [ __ ] the
presidency wait wait wait wait wait he
ran for president and was at one point a
front-runner but he's not interested in
being one of 15 cabinet members all of
which if you believe Armstrong Williams
were open to him because he lacks
experience but he thought that he could
be President of the United States yeah
you know secretary of health and human
services sounds like a lot of
responsibility I'd be better off as
president of the United States was this
some sort of strategic type of vanity
campaign I'm really unsure but now he's
positioned himself where he's in a place
to make millions as a keynote speaker
for hire yeah right we've long suspected
that Ben Carson's presidential run was
just a ploy to sell his books yet
because even when he was leading in the
Republican primaries he took some time
off from the campaign's real for all
important true yet fresh clothes but
isn't this a bit isn't this the problem
with vanity campaigns because you're
taking away resources from where they're
necessary of course and later Tuesday
Carson I guess realizing that the
initial explanation from Armstrong
Williams was a disaster came out with
his own clarification or something which
we will look at my decision not to seek
a cabinet position in the Trump
administration has nothing to do with
the complexity of the job as is being
reported by some news outlets I believe
it is vitally important for the Trump
administration to have many outspoken
friends and advisors who are outside of
the Washington bubble it is vital to
have independent voices of reason and
reconciliation if our nation is to heal
and regain its greatness I will continue
to work with the transition team and
beyond as we build a dynamite executive
branch of government I guess he's saying
he's more useful as an advisor than as a
cabinet member or something I truly
don't understand
this explanation and what I've come to
realize I think people in the audience
who have heard me talk about this before
it'll resonate with them the entire
Trump campaign and clearly the
administration is going to be governed
by something called the Peter Principle
I'm gonna put up for you what the peter
principle is the Peter Principle is a
concept in management theory that the
selection of a candidate for a position
is based on the candidates performance
in their current role rather than on
abilities relevant to the intended role
thus employees only stop being promoted
once they can no longer perform
effectively and managers rise to the
level of their in competence the best
example is imagine a fast-food
restaurant you get hired as a burger
flipper and you kill it you're just the
best burger flipper that there is out
there so you get promoted to the person
who rings that people up at the cat is
that you're the cashier you're now
taking the orders and because you were
able to learn the sort of technical
aspects of flipping burgers you're able
to learn the technical aspects of
collecting payment and running the cash
register and you're killing it as the
best damn cashier this fat fast food
place and because you stand out as the
best cashier you obviously have to get
promoted to shift supervisor except you
have absolutely no interpersonal skills
such that you could be managing and
delegating tasks so you get promoted up
until the point at which you're no
longer good at your job this is the
Peter Principle and it is very much at
play in the Trump administration yeah
and if we they take another look at that
Armstrong Williams quote it seems like
he was offered pretty much any position
he wanted that potatoes Secretary of
Defense Secretary of State yeah we're
gonna entrust ben Carson with those kind
of positions if that's true that's the
scariest part of the quote from
Armstrong Williams which is that not
only is he turning this down regardless
of whether or not it was formally
offered he could have had any one of
those positions and that is very very
scary and fortunately listen whatever
the reason it's good that ben Carson is
not going to be a secretary in the Trump
administration that is a very very good
thing i'm on twitter at a Packman we'll
take a break we've got patriot mail
coming
for you and much much more the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Marcia Harris Marcia thank you for
supporting alternatives to corporate
media you can sign up and join Marcia at
david pakman.com slash membership
remember that coupon code I voted 17 is
our post-election forty percent discount
you can also get a free 2017 david
pakman show calendar with your
membership at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 alright it is a new era for
hatred mail we have all sorts of new hey
treat male introductions that we will be
debuting including this one today
because it's time to make America hate
again patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate david pakman because america
and because freedom alright we get a
double dose of hatred mail today as you
know the anti-semitism has exploded
after the election of Donald Trump is
president-elect as I told you last week
it continues the first of two here we
talked about this one in particular it's
much more compelling when read
professionally that is episode 1 of 2
for today of patriot mail let's take a
listen you are a filthy jew [ __ ] you've
made russia the boogeyman for no reason
typical jew tactic all the elites are
left-wing godless jews right hey dumb
commie Jew you're not America you are a
despicable leftist leech that hates this
country and we hate you back you've been
trumped jew [ __ ] the Jew has been
defeated yeah so okay that was actually
the new one and then we will go also
because we are doing a double dose of
post Trump hate this is the the specific
one that I discussed in more detail
earlier this week
jus media fail you're nothing but an
inbred [ __ ] gas chamber rat Pakman no
one listened to this in June media this
election and no one ever will again
everyone is now aware of you [ __ ]
promoting white genocide you are [ __ ]
finished [ __ ] enjoy your new president
yes we're gonna be talking more about
this there has been a significant uptick
in this type of thing believe me I am I
am not the only person targeted by this
type of post Trump rhetoric we're gonna
get more into the data next what I can
say in the short run about this is uh
corporate media failed us we cannot
allow this type of thing and the Steve
bannon's and all of that to be
normalized in any way and the best ways
to support independent media which you
can do it david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code patriot 40
patriot 40 turn hatred mail into
something positive also get your
calendars at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 so we've been generally
talking about the up uptick in
anti-semitic hate incidents since the
election of Donald Trump is
president-elect of the United States the
anti-defamation league center on
extremism has been monitoring the
reports very very closely and they have
found a huge surge in the proliferation
of racist and anti-semitic graffiti and
vandalism this includes the use of
swastikas and other Nazi imagery there's
been a sharp spike in the reports of
these incidents as well as other
incidents related to identity hate which
we will talk about just a few examples
to to get a sort of started in crown
heights in brooklyn near my old
neighborhood in brooklyn a swastika was
spray painted on the sidewalk a hit
traditionally jewish neighborhood a
church in brown county indiana was
vandalized with a swastika and it said
uh hiyo silver spring church Trump as
well as homophobic slurs there was a
swastika and the words sig Heil 2016
spray-painted very early or late I guess
the weight
how you could sort of characterize it on
election night at a storefront in South
Philadelphia and nearby there was an SUV
spray painted with the words Trump rules
and Trump black [ __ ] and I had two
stories from being home in western
Massachusetts over the weekend where
there was a sort of rock face on a
hiking trail in east hampton
massachusetts that was covered in
anti-semitic Pro Trump graffiti as well
as a swastika carved into the sidewalk
near a synagogue in Greenfield
Massachusetts the stories go on and on
and on Rachel and the numbers don't lie
on this there is an emboldened of this
type of idea I don't think more people
believe this stuff right now than two
weeks ago but more people are emboldened
in making these beliefs public that's
what I think has changed there's been
not-so-subtle anti-semitism all
throughout Trump's campaign I don't know
if we're just forgetting that he's
retweeted neo-nazis you had that image
of Hillary Clinton with cash and a
Jewish star which he later changed to a
circle right and then he had that
closing image on his TV ad which had
Janet Yellen and George Soros and lloyd
blankfein so I I feel like this has been
a parent and now it's kind of coming to
the fore coming uh forth in that large
ways and the ADL has also been keeping a
close watch more generally pat on white
supremacists an extremist groups and
their reactions to the truck victory and
they're thrilled I mean there's an array
of white supremacist including those
associated with the alt right that are
celebrating Andrew Anglin unknown
neo-nazi who runs the daily stormer
website wrote a column talking about we
won and how great it all is James
Edwards is a white supremacist who runs
the political cesspool it's a radio show
based in Tennessee he wrote I hope
president Trump shows them no mercy
don't be magnanimous crush the defeated
especially those in the media and make
America great again Kevin McDonald a
well-known anti summit in a retired
professor wrote that trumps win is quote
a victory of white people over the oleg
ARCIC hostile elites read jews and
adding Trump's victory is a blow to the
entire Jewish power structure i guess
that's ignoring Trump's own daughter
who's Jewish they don't seem to care
about that or rationalizing a wet
rational
wising it away in any case this is
America now they love Trump's victory
you have to wonder what these
anti-semites think that a president
Trump is going to do for them right
because of sure sure I mean Steve
bannon's on his uh advisory team yeah
but president Trump president elect
Trump has a daughter a son-in-law and
grandchildren who are Jewish yeah and as
we talked about earlier in the show
Rachel mentioning Jared Kushner of
president-elect Trump's son-in-law
presumably going to have a pretty
significant role here I suggested
yesterday Rachel and I wonder what you
think about this that the reason that
the UH white supremacist right likes
Trump is not necessarily because of what
they think Trump will do but because the
entire scene is going to maybe make
those who fear the rise of white
supremacy lash out in some way which
will then justify violence against them
III mean I'm sort of reaching here but
I'm trying to figure out what it is that
they love because yet that you know the
Mexican walls pie never gonna happen the
Muslim ban probably isn't going to
happen although Trump's talking about
Muslim registration we'll deal with that
tomorrow what is it that they expect to
get from this I'm not really sure what
they expect to get from this but I hear
a lot of people saying that this is what
we are getting from a type of backlash
election very similar to Nixon's in 1968
and that our failure to address the
frustrations of the working white middle
class is is resulting in this yeah i
think that there's definitely a strong
element of that and there's also a
strong element of this is the first time
that white supremacy played a role
during the campaign and it wasn't
immediately dismissed by Trump he
eventually did disavow David Duke and
after saying he doesn't know who he is
even though he did etcetera etcetera but
that is definitely different this
campaign and the ADL is tracking it and
we're going to continue tracking it as
well there's a movement on the right
about racism which sort of ranges from
there's no such thing as racism to we
should never accuse anyone of being
racist to you can never really know if
someone is racist well there's a West
Virginia official uh who will uh now be
one who has resigned that another one
has been put on leave because of a
reference to Michelle Obama the first
lady as an ape in heels i'm referring to
pamela Ramsey Taylor the director of the
Clay County Development Corp which
provides services to elderly and
low-income residents the mayor of clay
West Virginia has also resigned as a
result of this and she was celebrating
the victory of Donald Trump in the
presidential election and the elevation
of Melania Trump to First Lady which is
very very scary to a lot of people and
she wrote it will be so refreshing to
have a classy beautiful dignified first
lady back in the White House I'm tired
of seeing a ape in heels not an ape but
uh ape Beverly wailing the mayor of clay
responded on facebook by saying that
just made my day Pam the mayor really
really liking this a petition calling
for wailing to be fired received more
than a hundred and twenty-one thousand
signatures as of midday yesterday in her
own apology the mayor denied that her
sentiments were racist bear in mind a
hundred twenty one thousand signatures
the town of clay has a population of 491
people none of whom are black according
to the latest census Clay County has
9,000 people 0.2% of which are black can
we say that this is a racist woman I get
that there's this movement path of we
can never call anyone racist because you
never know what it is that that they're
actually thinking if the first way that
comes to mind to criticize Michelle
Obama is as an ape in heels maybe you're
a little bit racist yeah we can tell
what they're thinking based on the words
that come out of their mouths and gotta
love how she gave this non-apology
saying that she's sorry to anyone that
she offends I love core have to own up
to what you what you did if you're gonna
be give a true apology I love those
apologies Rachel where the apology is if
anybody was offended it's an apology but
not I said something absolutely horrible
and there's no excuse or justification
whatsoever and people are talking about
free speech right everybody all any time
something like this happens people start
talking about free speech I believe in
free speech and I believe it is
absolutely fine to post this on Facebook
and to say it and for the mayor to say
wow
a breath of fresh air I really like what
you're saying I also believe that you
are not immune to the consequences of
your speech when we talk about free
speech in the First Amendment the
government can't prevent you from
stating your opinions everybody here
Rachel stated their opinions and those
opinions have consequences yeah and you
have to be cognizant of when you're
putting something on a public platform
as a public official you are probably
going to receive some attention on it
even if it's something positive or
something negative and its really again
no surprise that he 177 percent of the
vote there but another interesting thing
that I was kind of thinking about is I I
feel like this election and we've seen
we're now seeing this time and time
again has brought out really the
absolute kind of worst in humanity in
terms of all the racism and
anti-semitism that we're seeing which is
in it stark contrast what we saw when
Obama was elected and we kind of I saw a
lot of the opposite well what's
fascinating is President Obama's elected
and there is record uh uh racial and
identity based attacks against him and
then now that the president no longer is
the one with the sort of non agent
identity the attacks now are against
other groups that really are are
apparently upsetting to the Trump
supporters it's been sort of reversed
but in a way it's really just been a
redirection of who is being attacked
with these ideas and I I the the bottom
line on this is if you can't criticize a
black person without resorting to
calling them Apes maybe you've got
something going on racially there that
you need to really think about we're
going to take a break next I will speak
to read summers I won't tell you more
about this interview but I think you
will find it fascinating
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show i'm joined today in what i
think will be a very very interesting
interview by reid summer who's the
director of the society for the new
message from God he's the son of the
messenger Marshall V on summers I'm so
fascinated read by everything you guys
have going on over there if he for
people who aren't familiar first of all
with the Society for the new message
from God is this a church within a
religion is it a religion in and of
itself how do you describe it well first
and foremost it is a new message from
God it is a communication from the
creator of all life for people of all
religions and people of no religion so
first and foremost it is a message it is
also a worldwide community and a
movement worldwide amongst men and women
in over one hundred and six countries at
this point well who are undertaking a
return to their own natural innate
spirituality and seeking to find their
own unique contribution to a world in
need and what does that mean in terms of
the sort of physical manifestation is
there a physical building of prayer that
that exists or is this sort of a loosely
an amorphous community with with people
spread out throughout the world as you
mentioned in over a hundred countries
people spread out around the globe you
know we are based in Boulder Colorado
yeah but we have people everywhere
around the world our works are
translated into over 23 languages and we
gather global worldwide so it's a
worldwide movement of people really
rising up at this time of unbelievable
challenge conflict and division yeah in
our world rising up to make their own
unique contribution inspired by the
spiritual power which lives within them
and lives within all people so you're
not you are not a Christian organization
no we are not we're not we are a new Rev
elation a new message from the creator
of all life and God is open again yeah
that's what I want to get into so this
this entire thing sort of started around
the time that you were born roughly
speaking your father was was contacted
by God is that the way that it that it
was well 33 years ago my father was
called into the deserts of the American
Southwest by an angelic presence that
had been growing in his awareness for
years up to that point and at that
moment in the desert that presence
overcame him spoke through him right and
instructed him to record and was in any
kind of hallucinogenics at this time no
no he was you know he was actually a
teacher for blind children Oh before
that time yep he was simply this this
simply began to emerge in his life over
the course of years and culminated in
this encounter in the desert when he was
instructed to record and in the years
since he has done so and this voice of
revelation has spoken through him in
over eight hundred angelic encounters
and in so doing has delivered a new
message from the creator of all life for
all people speaking on almost every
imaginable aspect of world need and
personal need and why why your father in
other words why was your father the
recipient of such a message well the new
message from God says that my father was
sent from the angelic assembly into the
world to prepare to receive a pure and
complete communication from God to
humanity well he is a man you know he
has a human nature he has a pretty
amazing story challenging life journey
he's taken and it's not like for example
where Jesus some Christians believe
Jesus to be the sort of embodiment of
God on our planet your dad is just a
normal Homo sapiens he is a man in the
world absolutely he has a mind and a
body and a human nature he's an
immensely grounded why is compassionate
human being and yet there is something
else as I think you and your viewers
would would perhaps be able to see if
you were to meet him I think there is
something
Elsa deeper spiritual fire that he
carries that ignites people that moves
and empowers people well is this um I'm
i want to ask this question uh
delicately but I think it's an important
question for anybody who after this
interview is going to go and research
your organization uh there's questions
about whether it is a cult and I I
hesitate to use that term only because
it's a term that could be defined in so
many different ways so maybe we could
attack it from a couple of specific
angles do you encourage the followers of
the organization to sort of separate
from family and friends who may not uh
except what it is that are the teachings
of your father is that something that
the followers are encouraged to do
absolutely not no I mean we we are
people who have families extended
families we live in Muslim nations
Christian nations secular nations and we
are people who seek to bring the spirit
of this revelation which is really the
spirit at the heart of all religions
right and and moves in people who have
no religion we attempt to bring that
spirit into our families and and that is
the spirit of you know love and
compassion and forgiveness the ability
to listen to another and really
understand them and really get them so
in no way are we focused on separating
from this world we're focused on being
in this world but inspired at a deeper
level I've read with endless fascination
some of the instances you recalled from
your childhood including as young as 10
years old and and you have this story
which I don't want to tell for you but
the story I'm referencing just a jog
your memory is when you press your ear
up against the door of your dad's room
and you you both heard and felt
something right I was just thinking
about this the other day actually yeah
tiptoeing on all fours up the stairs at
the age of 10 because I heard a voice
upstairs and it was not the voice of my
father well and going up to the door
pressing the year to the door and
hearing this voice and I encourage you
know you and your listeners to go hear
this voice because for the first time in
history the voice that spoke to the
messengers of the past in the desert in
a cave at a burning bush
has been recorded and is available for
all people to hear and you believe that
is the god courage well this is the
voice this is the voice of revel at what
we call the voice of Revelation Boca it
is the will and intention of God beyond
language being communicated by the
angelic presence whether the messenger
so it is the voice of the angelic
assembly now why did I need to sneak up
in other words was that supposed to be a
private moment between the revealer and
your dad and you sort of uh were like a
fly on the wall or interrupted the party
so to speak to use a rather crude
analogy or why were you just not
included in that to begin with do you
think well you know every angelic
encounter has been recorded in its
original audio and as a kid I think I
was sensitive to the fact that I was
stomping and romping around the house
and throwing things and making general
noise and ruckus at a time at a moment
when something really important was
happening and I could feel as a child
this pervasive importance this
consequences gravity that my parents
carried being there very humble people
my mother was a nurse for decades
supporting my father you know my father
is a very even you know man of real kind
of solid and substance and and so
they're not extraordinary extravagant
people and yet here we are having a
normal family life and I'm a 10 year old
and I could feel the importance almost
fill the home you know pervade the space
and so tiptoeing up there to here i
think was was i just innately kind of
knew i should not you know stomp up the
stairs to here has this has this uh work
of uh of this is gospel i don't know if
that's the right term but has this
gospel that your father and and now you
are sort of putting out there for the
world has this made you guys very very
wealthy no not at all my mother retired
from her nursing profession two years
ago my father took no compensation for
decades yeah absolutely not in any way
and i mean this is this is an effort to
bring a message of activation activating
the human heart to people adding very
painful desperate time in the world and
i think given the events of last week
you
the world is roiling in this feeling of
anxiety and confusion and frustration
because I'm feeling about now for sure I
i I'm sure you are in I mean maybe what
we're feeling is here we are at this
amazing cusp in the world where climate
change is accelerating human mass
migration is sweeping continents okay we
have an environmental calamity on our
hands and yet humanity has not come
together sat down at the table and
cooperated sufficiently yeah no doubt I
I think yeah and and really what the new
message is here to do is to call forth a
greater good in the human family so
how's like I mean you're getting into
some political issues there are it does
your organization take a view on
something as earthly as gay marriage for
example or the medical procedure known
as abortion are those things that you
you guys take a position on or that God
has through your dad as you mentioned
well the new message supports and
advocates certain things in the world
doesn't call call for exact policies but
it does honor and recognize individuals
who have a gay orientation and says that
gay relationships can possess a higher
purpose and meaning resonance with
individuals now that is not like most of
religious folks that I've spoken to I'll
tell you that this is a new revelation
it is new and it is fresh and it is
renewed and it is not denigrating anyone
it honors and respects the existing
faiths and their communities and says
that they and their faith tradition are
part of God's ongoing plan to serve the
world well and so this is not about
creating an elite group and you know
that that is going to be redeemed and
saved and empowered above all others
yeah this is about calling everyone back
to the heart of their spirituality of
their tradition even if they have no
tradition yeah so that the good can come
from too many places to be stopped in
the world hey last thing i want to touch
on in the limited time we have is there
any sort of rapture or apocalypse
prediction through the messenger that
you guys have received from from god the
new message from god this is not the end
of times no message makes that clear
this is the beauty
transition to a different kind of new
world reality a world of declining
resources a world where cooperation and
unity and compassion have got to be
paramount and so there is great urgency
in the new message make no mistake it is
it is speaking in no uncommon terms of
the global crisis in which we live yeah
and yet no there is no end times there's
no chosen time when certain people will
be elevated beyond others the human
family goes on and the question is in
what spirit does it go on yeah how
unified is it and are we going to
continue to degrade and plunder the
world threatening the very foundations
of human civilization Wow well read
summers you've said it all I don't know
what I could possibly add to this you
really have director of the Society for
the new message from God I think our
audience will really have a lot to look
into after this interview and I really
do thank you for talking to us about the
new message and I for one found it
absolutely fascinating thank you so much
to do fishing having the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
megyn kelly Fox News hurt Megyn Kelly's
new memoir is making a lot of news and I
want to sort of look at a couple aspects
of this she says in her upcoming memoir
that president elect Trump often tried
to offer her gifts in exchange for
positive coverage during the 2016
election this is major particularly
because she says that although she
didn't accept any of the gifts there
were journalists who she doesn't name
that accepted gift from Donald Trump the
associated press reported yesterday
about an excerpt from her memoir settle
for more which says that Trump would
give journalists and commentators if
they were willing to talk him up and if
they wanted different gifts including
free airfare free stays at Trump's
various properties let's put up a quote
here from settle for more by megan kelly
this is actually one of the untold
stories of the 2016 campaign i was not
the only journalist to whom trump
offered gifts clearly meant to shape
coverage Trump tried to work the refs
and some of the refs responded this is
smart because the media is full of
people whose egos need stroking saying
that Trump would work with certain TV
hosts also to come up with criticism for
himself so they wouldn't be seen as
being in the tank for Donald Trump but
she says she resisted these offers which
included like a girls weekend at Trump's
downtown Manhattan hotel or flying her
and her husband to his mar-a-lago estate
in Florida one little question that
comes up for me is why on earth is this
an untold story this should have been a
major story during the campaign megan
kelly could have been the hero who went
public with it but i guess going public
with it during the campaign doesn't
benefit her as much as publishing it in
her memoir after the campaign is over
well yeah it's a hush hush because of
course the journalists aren't going to
reveal that this is what happened
someone should overcome this ethical
conundrum and break the story and she
probably should have done that here yeah
she's emerging now is the most sought
after star and television news and
getting offers for contracts about 20
million and quite frankly even if she
had made this admission before I don't
think it would have chained
anything no i'm at like we know Trump
could shoot people on Fifth Avenue he
could make fun of disabled people oh he
did he could uh talk about grabbed by
the [ __ ] oh he did that he could talk
about women being pigs oh he did that as
well none of these things affected him
so the fact that he was trying and
apparently according to megan kelly
successfully bought journalists off
would not likely have changed the
election results but it would have been
nice of her to bring it up and like
Trump megyn kelly is a very smart person
who is selling her book she wants to
sell it to the largest number of people
possible left and right and more than
likely she is going to successfully do
that because a lot of what is in this
book is very very compelling her also
though and I want to make sure we get to
this other aspect megyn kelly is also
now coinciding with the release of her
memoir talking about how yes Roger Ailes
the embarrassed Fox News chief harassed
her as well she was a victim of sexual
harassment at the hands of former Fox
new CEO Roger Ailes she went on the dr.
Phil show I don't know that we very
often play clips of the dr phil show on
this program but i have a little bit of
it and it is absolutely fascinating and
you'll remember that in the wake of all
sorts of women coming out and saying you
know I was also victimized sexually
harassed by roger ailes megyn kelly was
criticized for waiting very long in the
game to come out and say you know yeah I
i also am aware of some of this stuff
and etcetera etcetera i think that that
was not a good critique of megyn kelly
we know all of the different reasons why
it is perfectly normal and common and
logical for many victims of sexual
harassment not to be overly eager to go
out and to make those allegations public
that being said she is doing it now here
is a clip from her talking to dr. Phil
yesterday were you sexually harassed by
roger ailes yes beginning with my
problems with Roger began when I was at
the company for 12 months so I was a
first year reporter and I was called up
to New York britt hume my direct manager
in the DC bureau told me i had captured
the attention of mr. rails
and told me that he wanted to see me in
New York so I went up to New York I was
working in the Washington DC bureau and
I went up there I had met with him I
think once before you know for my job
interview but this was a great moment
for me because you want to capture the
attention of your boss and he gave me a
bunch of advice you know I went into his
office he gave me a bunch of advice but
the problem with that meeting and with
several that happened over the next six
months was not only was there legitimate
professional advice but there were
grossly inappropriate comments he had
always had an inappropriate sense of
humor you know they is not PC and this
was actually something we liked about
him I mean he's he'll crack a dirty joke
or drop a swear and so will I I that I
don't judge that you know I don't speak
the Queen's English either as you'll see
in the book there i mean just FYI yeah
by the book um many copies but this was
something different this was specific
comments about my body how he wanted to
see me and it grew more severe over time
like what was he give me an example well
like he said he knew I must have some
very sexy bras and you'd like to see me
in them that smooth operator Roger Ailes
man that go get that gets the women
every time when you tell them I'm going
to guess at what you have in your
underwear drawer at home uh so obviously
the response from from Roger Ailes is
lawyer not surprising which is this is
all bogus but the more interesting
response to me was from Bill O'Reilly
who went on CBS yesterday any said he's
not interested in making the network
look bad at all and then he added the
following on his own show which I'll put
up on the screen for you if somebody is
paying you a wage yoooo that person or
company allegiance you don't like what's
happening in the workplace go to human
resources or leave I've done that and
then take the action you need to take
afterward if you feel aggrieved there
are labor laws in this country but don't
run down the concern that supports you
by trying to undermine it bill oreilly
seems to see this as just sort of like a
PR issue for fox and employee relations
rather than the fact that they had a
serial sexual
reser on staff for Bill O'Reilly it's
more about the right positioning of how
you complain and when into who and
making my network look bad Bill O'Reilly
seems to see sexual harassment as a PR
issue which makes sense because it
became a major PR issue for him when he
was talking to andrea makris about it
you know pleasuring herself and all
sorts of stuff this has clearly been a
big PR issue for Bill O'Reilly but he
doesn't see this as an issue of sexual
harassment which is really what it is
well that's also coming from someone who
has been accused of sexual harassment
but I think what's also interesting here
is that where megyn kelly is position
now because she has to try and kind of
appeal to her new lean in fan base while
also balancing that with a lot of Fox
News watchers who really hate identity
politics yeah where does that leave her
I think it's super interesting actually
I'm not a big fan of megan kelly Pat but
I think that what she is doing here the
timing of it of course is is very
susceptible to the sort of motivation of
selling books and there's no doubt she's
going to sell a lot of books for this uh
for these appearances but she's
positioned herself in a really
interesting place now where she is both
seen as the sort of commanding
up-and-coming television star but also
someone who is not going to be pushed
around even if it's about sexual
harassment by a male superior which is
not exactly a position that lots of her
fan base is super thrilled to be out in
front of and criticizing publicly and
all the allegations that she's given so
far seem to have happened right when she
started working for Fox News yeah she
continued to get promotions got uh very
generous maternity leave so yep you have
to wonder if this kind of thing
continued and she's just keeping quiet
about it there that's the other aspect
of it which is do you sort of become
immune to this when you have higher
status in the network we saw that
gretchen carlson who not as well known
as as megan kelly and not of the same uh
sort of a stature on the network seemed
to be continually subjected to this type
of thing of course Roger Ailes denies at
all at this point really no reason to
believe the denials we have a voicemail
number it's 2192 david p we have not
heard from the louisiana troll for a
while but he has really been activated
by the results of last week's election
and and i want to hear from him now
you know what sucks back man of the fact
that Democrats will never win another
national election and I'm going to tell
you what okay uh itself does bring back
jobs to the rough stuff and pretty much
a lot of you know kind of the rural
South America where there are minorities
by the way unlike what you think
minorities don't just all live in
inner-city ghettos like you left this
like to uh to claim for some real racist
reason um they are going to see well
here's here's the thing you left it use
minorities as a tool for Democrat votes
that's it and I could prove that by two
different things just look how nasty you
guys are to minorities who don't vote uh
deep I me just turn to you know Ana
Kasparian video which she unleashed on
women who vote for Trump call them all
stupid idiots or look at some of your
videos for you call uh you know minority
still both he uncle tom some other yeah
Steve natural English met the Louisiana
troll calls in and everything all his
comments are based on things that just
have never happened I feel like he's
watching other shows any thinks it's
this show any calls in leaves us
voicemail number one it was Trump
actually who talked about inner cities
interchangeably with talking about
minorities it's Trump who made that
assumption and number two when have we
ever called any Republic person who
doesn't vote for a Democrat and Uncle
Tom we haven't and in fact the data
demonstrates that there is no
justification to the idea that black
voters in 08 in 2012 voted for President
Obama because he was black so Louisiana
troll it's always great to hear from him
I guess not really but I guess it's okay
to hear from him but you've got to call
in about stuff that we've actually
set we've got a great bonus show for you
today please become members you'll get
instant access
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you
you